we have to talk about this photo with
Miss Shania Twain young gravy and your
caption here gravy Shania Twain soon
okay what was discussed with Miss Shania
Twain and what is up your sleeves so I
I've actually been uh riding country for
artists a lot lately and
um I'm kind of getting into that I don't
know it just kind of fits even though
I've I've written rap for people but the
country just kind of worked out and I um
I met Shania last night and we bonded a
lot over the fact that like she lives in
Switzerland I'm a Swiss citizen it all
worked out real well but they want us to
come out to their their place in Lake
Geneva
and Report some stuff okay so when you
would go into a session like that with
Shania what would you bring to the table
what would you want to see her do
I mean I'd probably try to get around
some trap stuff you know I'd probably
try to get her to start you know
featuring a rap track but uh you know I
probably let her handle the Melodies and
I'll do the lyrics that's how I usually
do it in sessions but yeah get her on
some trap how much fun have you had
working with the country artists and
also like who remind me who you've been
working with
so I've been uh pretty close with Hardy
and Morgan Wallen I was just at Hardy's
release party last week and we got a lot
of videos
I'm going to stay at his place in in
Nashville soon uh so I'm gonna get some
country riding in there and then I guess
next time I'm in Switzerland I'll do it
with Shania Twain baby
foreign